Es ist Länderspielpause in der 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Wir wollen aber nach dem vierten Spieltag und dem Ende der Transferphase noch einmal einen Blick auf einige Vereine werfen. Und das mache ich jetzt mit Thomas Haufe vom Nur der FCM Podcast und Kevin Bublitz vom Paracast. Viel Spaß!
Und nun im Programm– der Rasenfunk.
Lagerheim fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor.
Und Augsburg ist open.
Kroffi ist zu kurz ab, der lang genug für Willi Landgraf. Wagner, Martin Wagner.
Und das 1 zu 0.
Markus Kurt aus dem Gewühl.
Alexander Schur!
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Ja, willkommen zurück zur zweiten Ligatour quasi. Ich bin Eva-Lotta Bohle. Ich bin ein Teil des Hostteams für die Rasenfunk Ligatour zur zweiten Bundesliga der Männer. Und zu Beginn dieser Sendung darf ich mich erst mal sehr über euer Feedback zur ersten regulären Folge dieses neuen Formats bedanken. Es war ja auch durchaus gemischt und ich glaube, das spiegelt auch ganz gut wieder, dass wir eben uns erstmal so ein bisschen finden müssen mit diesem neuen Format. Auch ein bisschen gucken, wie funktioniert es am besten für unsere Gäste. Denn an denen liegt ja die Hauptaufgabe in diesen Sendungen. Und das ist meine perfekte Überleitung. Denn ich darf zwei weitere Mitglieder unseres All-Star-Teams vorstellen. Zum einen ist da Thomas Haufe vom Nur der FCM-Podcast. Hallo Thomas.
Ja, hallo. Schönen guten Tag.
Und auch Kevin Bublitz dürfen wir mal wieder hier begrüßen. Ihr kennt ihn sicherlich auch vom Paracast. Hallo Kevin.
Hi. Moin, moin.
So gleich doppelt Moin, Moin. Nicht, dass uns jetzt hier Hamburger Zuhörerinnen und die Barrikanen gehen. Aber die hören uns jetzt eh nicht mehr, ne? Die sind ja jetzt eh in der Bundesliga. Aber ich muss zu Beginn sagen, eigentlich ganz witzig, weil euch gab es schon mal in dieser Konstellation, und zwar nicht mit mir, aber mit Marc. Und ja, da habt ihr ein bisschen noch über eure Vereine, ich glaube noch so halb im Aufstiegskampf, gesprochen. Das ist jetzt ein bisschen anders, aber wir wollen den Finger jetzt auch nicht zu sehr in die Wunde legen, sondern in diese neue Saison grutschen und eben sagen, die ist erst vier Spieltage alt. Aber der August ist vorbei und das bedeutet natürlich auch, vor der August vorbei ist, ist auch das Transferfenster, man könnte sagen, endlich geschlossen. Ich weiß nicht, wie es euch ging, aber diese letzten Tage, die waren als Fan, als auch als so leicht journalistischer Bad, durchaus sehr anstrengend. Wie habt ihr das gesehen?
Also wenn ich anfangen darf, absolut. Ich bin seit vielen Jahren dafür, dass mit Anpfiff der Saison auch die Transferphase enden muss. Ich finde, das ist ein großes Unding. Ich finde auch nach wie vor keine Begründung, die mir einleuchtet, wieso das nicht so ist. Außer natürlich, dass man noch ganz gut Geld machen kann und dass Spieler, die natürlich unter einem z.B. neuen Trainer nicht in die Mannschaft finden, dann noch die Chance haben, woanders zu landen. Aber ich bin froh. Wir hatten ja in Perlaborne einige Themen und es hat uns ja auch nochmal getroffen, dass das jetzt dann auch vorbei ist.
Thomas, wie ist es bei dir?
Schließe ich mich komplett an, sehe ich ganz genauso. Man sollte auch immer so eine Fenster zu haben.
Ich hoffe, ihr versteht den Hinweis. Ich sage mal so, mehr oder weniger wurde ich darum gebeten, dass wir das jetzt nicht zu ausführlich besprechen. Googelt das doch einfach. Martin Kass oder Martijn Kass und Fenster. Mir wurde auch gesagt, ich soll bitte Schallusi sagen, auch wenn sich der Umgang einfach anstellt.
Um Himmels willen, bitte nicht.
Da kommt ja kurz das Osten aus Westfalen durch oder so, könnte man sagen. Gut, wir sind jetzt Spaß beiseite. Wie gesagt, das war ja gefühlt für mehrere Vereine nochmal auch gar nicht mal so unwichtig auf dem Transfermarkt nochmal nachzulegen. Generell hatte da Kevin tatsächlich eine ganz interessante Entdeckung gemacht. Willst du vielleicht einfach mal sagen, was dir da so aufgefallen ist?
Ja, was heißt Entdeckung? Ich habe mir halt angeguckt, weil wir ein bisschen über das Transferfenster sprechen wollten, wie viele Spieler sind gegangen, wie viele sind gekommen. Dabei bin ich so ein bisschen über die Ausgabeneinnahmensituation gestolpert und fand das recht spannend, wie die Differenzen da doch waren. Ja, schon deutlich. Die Vereine haben ja im Vergleich zu dem, was sie ausgegeben haben für neue Spieler, deutlich Plus gemacht, so gesehen. Und du hattest ja dann auch noch eine Tafel, die habe ich dann nicht mehr gefunden, aber die hast du mir ja geschickt. Oder noch mal zu sehen, dass bis auf drei Vereine auch alle wirklich Plus gemacht haben, um es mal so zu formulieren, was das Transferfenster angeht.
Vier sogar, sorry. Vier Vereine haben einen negativen Transferfenster.
Ah ja, stimmt, da ist auch noch ein. Richtig, vier. Siehste. Ja, das fand ich relativ beachtlich, weil ich das gar nicht so erwartet hätte, dass das so ist, vor allem, weil es auch ziemlich deutlich war. Also ich kann es einmal sagen, die Quelle ist ja auch nicht geheim. transfermarkt.de 116 Millionen zusammen gerundet an Transfer-Einnahmen und nur 44 aufgerundet an Ausgaben. Finde ich schon krass. Also hätte ich jetzt nicht so gedacht. Aber es beschreibt so ein bisschen auch, finde ich, die Entwicklung der 2. Liga als noch viel mehr als es früher war, finde ich, als Sprungbrett in die höheren Profiligen. Früher hast du ja oft so den Charakter gehabt, als ein 2. Liga-Spieler, typischer 2. Liga-Spieler. Heute hast du ganz oft ganz viele Vereine drin, die wirklich Spieler drin haben, offenbar, die dann den Sprung nutzen, ob es jetzt ins Ausland danach ist oder halt in die Bundesliga. Aber ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass das so deutlich ist. Für mich unterstreicht das so ein bisschen die Bilanz. Ich hoffe, ich werde dafür nichts erfügt im Forum.
Ich kann ja einmal ganz kurz sagen, wer diese vier 2. Ligisten sind, die halt ein negatives Transfersaldo gemacht haben, das sind eben von der geringsten bis zur höchsten Summe Dresden-Bielefeld, finde ich auch immer ganz spannend, dass da eben zwei Aussteiger dabei sind. Obwohl man auch zwischen Dresden und Bielefeld noch einen deutlichen Unterschied sieht. Dann ist es die Spielvereinigung Fürth und Preußen-Münster. Die haben tatsächlich den höchsten mit 1,7 Millionen. Das ist umgerechnet in der Bundesliga fast der geringste. Ich glaube, da hat St. Pauli den geringsten negativen Transfersaldo. Finde ich glaube 1,45 Millionen. Ich habe das generell, weil man wird ja immer gesagt, Bundesliga wird mit England verglichen. Ich habe jetzt einfach mal die 2. Liga mit der Champions League verglichen. Das ist schon relativ witzig. Da haben 11 von 24 Vereinen den negativen Saldo am meisten. Da übrigens der AFC Wrexham mit über 37 Millionen Euro. Das finde ich schon absurd, da mal diesen Vergleich zu ziehen. Du hast es eben gesagt, Transferausgaben bei 286 Neuzugängen. Das liegt bei fast 44 Millionen Euro in der 2. Liga. Bei 392 Neuzugängen in der Champions League bei 321 Millionen Euro. Da muss man eben sagen, ich habe dann noch mal geguckt, da unterscheidet sich zum Beispiel Bundesliga und Champions League gar nicht so, dass man immer mehr noch Einnahmen als Ausgaben hat. Aber eben da sehr viel mehr beieinander. Da kannst du das überhaupt nicht miteinander vergleichen wie mit der 2. Liga. Ja, übrigens witzig, ich glaube, bei der Champions League haben genau so viele– nee, bei der Bundesliga– es gibt genauso viele laut Transfermarkt, Neuzugänge wie Abgänge, 262. Fand ich witzig. Komisch, ne? Ich bin in den Rabbit Hole gefallen. Das ist ja nicht eigentlich natürlich, dass es genauso viele Neuzugänge wie Zugänge gibt. So funktioniert der Markt ja eigentlich dann doch nicht. Aber gut, bevor wir jetzt weiter in das Transferfenster gehen, würde ich euch doch einmal gerade fragen. Ihr musstet ja auch zum Beginn der Saison so Transfer, äh Transfer, sage ich jetzt schon, das andere T-Wort Tabellentipps abgeben. Und Thomas, ich frage einfach mal dich, also du musst jetzt nicht deine Tabellentipps analysieren nach dem vierten Spieltag. Aber magst du vielleicht erst mal sagen, was dir denn generell so zu Beginn der 2. Liga aufgefallen ist, der neuen Saison? Was gefällt dir? Wo sagst du, boah, das hat mich auch vielleicht überrascht, im Positiven wie Negativen?
Na, ich glaube, überrascht im negativen Sinne, fangen wir da mal an. Ich glaube, da sind wir uns alle einig, das ist härter. Da hat, denke ich, keiner so richtig mit gerechnet. Biedelfeld hat mich bestätigt, ist für mich kein typischer Aufsteiger, ist für mich eigentlich eine Mannschaft, die– ich eigentlich auch gesagt habe– für mich sind die auf jeden Fall unter den ersten acht in der Saison. Die Pokalgelder, die da eingenommen wurden, letzte Saison, ich glaube, die konnte man auch gut refinanzieren. Von daher ist Biedelfeld für mich absolut kein klassischer Aufsteiger. Bei Dresden sieht das anders aus, die spielen so, wie man es erwarten könnte. Ja, ansonsten Überraschung. Paderborn ist für mich besser gestartet, als ich gedacht hätte. Düsseldorf, glaube ich, auch eine kleine Delle am Anfang gehabt, wobei die sich, denke ich, auch gefangen haben jetzt. Und wo man auch sagen muss, vielleicht auch erwartbar gewesen in meinen Augen, wie ihr das seht, Nürnberg. Hatten auch krasse Abgänge und konnten das in meinen Augen nicht so richtig auffangen. Aber, glaube ich, die positivste Überraschung ist für mich definitiv Elbersberg. Ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass die mit den Abgängen Trainer weg, dann wirklich mit Aslani, Damar und Baumehinden, dass da die, sagen wir, drei absolute Leistungsträger verloren, die da durch Laien wieder zurückgegangen sind zu ihren Stammvereinen und auch der Trainer dann weg. Und das scheint überhaupt nicht zu jucken. Also schon beeindruckend.
Bevor ich dich frage, Kevin, einmal zu Nürnberg noch, da hatten wir ja vor zwei Wochen noch mit Lisa Höfer drüber gesprochen. Ich weiß noch, haben lang und breit über Caspar Janda diskutiert und ob er denn jetzt geht oder nicht. Ist jetzt nicht zu Stuttgart gegangen, aber dann natürlich, ja, nach England hat dann doch das Geld gerufen. Von daher tut Nürnberg dann auch nicht besser. Aber Kevin, wie sieht es denn bei dir aus? Wie schaust du auf den Start der neuen Saison?
Ja, ich habe, glaube ich, härter oben getippt gehabt. Das Ding ist so, ich habe eigentlich, ich wollte dieses Jahr mal so ein, da kommen wir gleich auch bei der Mannschaft, die für mich das Transferfenster gewonnen hat drauf. Da hast du ja gesagt, ja, ich habe die einfachste Wahl getroffen, oder die offensichtlichste. Und ich dachte, ich mache das diesmal auch bei den Tabellenplätzen so und habe deswegen härter genommen, weil die natürlich mit Abstand das meiste Budget haben, wobei wir in den letzten Jahren gelernt haben, dass das nicht unbedingt immer zwangläufig dazu führen muss, dass man oben spielt. Ich habe nur gedacht, dass der Leitwilder besser klarkommt. Ja, habe mich wohl betäuscht. Das ist halt gar nichts. Das ist eine Nullnummer. Was mich am meisten überrascht hat, ist Schalke, glaube ich. Eigentlich war es für mich der Geheimtipp auch. Ich wollte ihn auch mal machen. Tatsächlich, wirklich. Ich habe die auf Platz 3 geschrieben oder auf Platz 2. Habe es aber mich dann doch nicht getraut, weil ich mir dachte, dann werde ich auch wieder zerrissen. Und alle lachen über mich. Ja, jetzt sind sie oben und ich glaube, weil sie die Spiele gerade ganz schmutzig gewinnen, teilweise und sehr eng, sind sie für mich die Überraschung und werden für mich auch am Ende wahrscheinlich da oben drin bleiben und stehen. Das ist nach vier Spieltagen wahrscheinlich sehr optimistisch, da schon so eine Tendenz auszumachen. Aber ich finde, Schalke hat dieses Spiel letztes Jahr alle verloren, die sie jetzt gewonnen haben und sind wirklich durch ein großes Teil der Tränen gelaufen, also wirklich mit Themen, so wie der HSV eigentlich auch die letzten Jahre immer draufgetreten. Alle haben sich gefreut, Schadenfreude hier und da Schalke 3. Liga. Ich glaube, dass irgendwann in diesem Verein hoffentlich auch mal so eine, ja, weiß ich nicht, Klärungsgedanke durchgelaufen ist, dass man sich mal auf neue Tugenden besinnt und vielleicht auch mal diese ganzen Schmutzgeschäfte hinter den Kulissen hinter sich gelassen hat. Und ich glaube, Schalke ist für mich die Überraschung. Und dann eigentlich Hannover 96. Für mich der absolute Topfavorit auf den Aufstieg dieses Jahr wirklich. Die letzten Jahre haben ja alle Experten drauf getippt. Ich glaube, die haben jetzt endlich den Trainer bekommen, der das machen kann. Die haben einen coolen Trainerstab auch bekommen. Die haben sich ja auch klugerweise in Paderborn auch bedient.
Ich sehe, hier in der Runde wurde mit FCM und Paderborn der Ausstieg von Hannover 96 quasi gebaut.
Eduard Schmidt ist ein super Coach im Trainerstab von Kvassniok gewesen. Hat mich sehr gewundert, dass er den nicht mitgenommen hat nach Köln. Und hat mich trotzdem auch überrascht, dass er dann nicht in Paderborn geblieben ist, sondern nach Hannover gegangen ist. Und ich glaube, dass insgesamt eine gute Zusammenstellung ist, die Tizt da genommen hat und die Spieler auch sehr klug gewählt, auch dann wirklich mal sich von einem Zieler getrennt. Identifikationsfigur kann aber sicherlich gerne nach seiner Karriere wieder zurückkommen in den Verein. Und geht es halt nochmal woanders, andere Wege. Also ich glaube, Hannover ist dieses Jahr reif für einen Aufstieg.
Ja, ich würde einen Verein noch nennen, den habt ihr bei. Nein, noch nicht genannt. Das ist Eintracht Braunschweig. Hat sicherlich auch was damit zu tun, dass ich sie eben vor der Länderspielpause auch live gegen Bielefeld gesehen habe. Und natürlich auch einfach dieses Pokalspiel gegen den VfB Stuttgart. Also wer das nicht gesehen hat, der hat, glaube ich, also muss man glaube ich wirklich ganz unironisch sagen, eines der besten Erstrundenspiele sowieso im Pokal gesehen. Also was heißt besten, aber halt der aufregendsten, würde ich fast sagen, mit diesem immer wieder wechselnden Spielverlauf, mit dem Elfmeterschießen, wo man hinterher wirklich noch Spieler finden musste, bei Braunschweig, die überhaupt den Weg von der Mittellinie bis zum Elfmeterpunkt irgendwie beschreiten konnten. Aber da hatte ich auch das Gefühl, was ich so bei Braunschweig-Fans gelesen habe und wir haben ja auch mit Anna Lautenbach bei uns einem All-Star-Team dabei, die eben Eintracht-Fan ist. Und ich glaube, das hat ganz vielen Eintracht-Fans einfach unfassbar viel zurückgegeben. Also was, was sie die letzten drei, vier Jahre einfach so nicht hatten, ist einfach eine Mannschaft, die Bock hat, Fußball zu spielen, die kämpft, die eben alles reinwirft, wie man so schön sagt. Und die durchaus auch mit dem Ball immer mehr lernen, Fußball zu spielen. Also das gegen Bielefeld war jetzt kein sonderlich schönes Spiel. Du hast eben bei Braunschweig auch irgendwann gesehen, dass die Kräfte einfach schwinden. Aber sie haben da durchaus ein vernünftiges System unter einer Backe aus, was zu funktionieren scheint. Ich glaube jetzt tatsächlich nicht, dass sie sich oben festsetzen können. Aber ich glaube halt einfach, dass die, wenn sie so weitermachen, nur entspannteren Saisons spielen. Und ich glaube, das ist ja genau das, was man bei Braunschweig sehen wollte, eine Entwicklung in der Mannschaft. Und muss ich sagen, Respekt, ehrlich gesagt, hätte ich so nicht erwartet.
Das ist ein interessanter Punkt auf jeden Fall. Ich habe tatsächlich an den ersten zwei Spieltagen auch gedacht, krass, was ist mit denen los? Und wenn ich deine Tabelle, die du geschickt hast, gerade so im Augenwinkel sehe, haben sie am zweitwenigsten investiert in die Mannschaft, nur 750.000 Euro. Da bin ich wirklich gespannt, ob sie das dann halten können, das Niveau. Ich weiß, die Mannschaft, wo ich so ein bisschen drüber spreche, die hat auch nur einen Platz höher, auf Platz 16. Da haben wir auch nur 850.000 Euro investiert. Und dafür am zweitmeisten fast die zweitbeste. Weißt du, was haben sie? Saldo, das drithöchste Saldo von in der ganzen 2. Liga, der erste Paderborn. Ja, aber Braunschalke bin ich gespannt. Ich traue den Braten nicht so ganz. Ich hatte mich auch, ehrlich gesagt, in der Rückrunde gewundert. Wieso Daniel Scherning auf einmal und so. Aber da habe ich keine Ahnung, hab nicht hinterhinkriegt, es sind gar keine Infos, wie es da dann so kurz vor Ende noch zur Trennung gab und so. Ja, aber da hast du recht. Also das Pokalspiel war irre. Das hat echt Spaß gemacht aus neutraler Sicht sowieso. Wand, die hatte ich jetzt wirklich nicht auf dem Schirm als Überraschung, weil sie wahrscheinlich jetzt gerade schon wieder im Mittelfeld irgendwo stehen.
Ja, gut, das ist nach vier Spieltagen natürlich auch immer so relativ. Da muss man ja fast sagen.
Kota Fürth ist vielleicht noch in der Überraschung auch, nach der letzten Saison.
Ja, bei Fürth, ich glaube, da ist bei mir der Beipunkt, wo ich den Brat nicht traue. Also liebe Grüße auch nochmal an Michi Fischer. Aber ich glaube, der traut den Brat noch nicht. Und das ist also gefühlt ist da um einiges weniger System hinter als bei Braunschweig, wenn ich das mal so sagen darf, ohne dann doch so viel fürzugucken freiwillig, I'm sorry, wie andere Menschen.
Ich will jetzt gerade über zwei Vereine sprechen, gegen die wir beide verloren haben. Naja, egal.
Sorry, das war keine Ahnung.
Aber es gibt ja auch die Theorie, passt jetzt hier nicht so ganz. Aber der MacBook ist ja fast aufgestiegen, deswegen kann man vielleicht die Theorie doch anwenden, dass Mannschaften, die es gerade nicht geschafft haben oder abgestiegen sind, am Anfang so am leichtesten zu schlagen sind. Insofern kannst du vielleicht noch Hoffnung haben, dass es zum späteren Zeitpunkt nicht mehr gegen euch schaffen wird.
Ich bin sehr, sehr positiv immer noch gestimmt, was unsere Mannschaft angeht.
Na gut.
Ja, wir sehen ja mal, wie das dann Freitagabend um, weiß ich nicht, 20.30 Uhr aussieht, für wen. Ah ja, ah ja, so angesslustig, ja. Okay. Lass uns doch jetzt tatsächlich mal so ein bisschen auf das Transferfenster gucken und ja, ich glaube einfach so die ganz großen Änderungen wie in der Bundesliga gab es jetzt doch nicht. Das heißt, wir gehen jetzt nicht irgendwie jeden Verein durch, weil das würde den Rahmen hier auch komplett sprengen. Wir haben mal so ein bisschen geguckt, wer hat denn für uns waren denn so die Gewinner. Ich kann schon mal sagen, zwei von uns haben sich festgelegt, einer von uns so halb. Aber ich fange mal mit dem an, der sich festgelegt hat und immer schon mal hat einfließen lassen in diesem Gespräch bisher. Wer denn für ihn der Gewinner ist und deshalb Kevin, starte doch gerne rein.
Ja, er ist natürlich auch dem Staat geschuldet, aber ich glaube, der ist eben nicht unbegründet, ist Hannover 96. Die haben, das war mir gar nicht so bewusst bis so kurz, die haben wirklich auch sehr viele Spieler ausgetauscht, haben sehr viele Spieler abgegeben, viele Spieler neu geholt, auch vermeintliche Leistungsträger oder auch altgediente Spieler abgegeben, losgeworden, wie auch immer man das nennen möchte. Ihr habt ja auch einen bekommen in Bielefeld.
Zwei, bitte. Obwohl Markus Mann gesagt hat, es wechselt kein Spieler in diesem Sommer von Hannover nach Bielefeld. Ich musste diesen Satz noch einmal rauskramen, damit beende ich das Thema von mir aus auf jeden Fall.
Sie haben sehr, sehr klug nachgelegt, glaube ich. Das scheint sich auch zu manifestieren. Tiz hat bisher gar keine Anlaufschwierigkeiten mit dem Team gehabt. Es ist ja ein Clean Sweep, vier Siege, acht zu zwei Tore. Momentan wirkt das, da kann man ja schon fast gar nicht mehr nach so einem Frühstart irgendwie von dem Frühstart sprechen, sondern die wirken gerade in Top-Form irgendwie schon. Und zumindest haben in den vier Spielen plus Pokal keine Mannschaft so richtig, ja in der Liga zumindest keine Mannschaft, den Weg gefunden, sie zu knacken oder sie überhaupt vor Schwierigkeiten zu stellen. Das habe ich im Sommer, als da so ein bisschen tabula rasa gemacht wurde und ich dann wusste, dass Tiz dahin geht, nicht komplett so erwartet, weil ich glaube, Tiz ist eigentlich auch ein Typ, der eine Mannschaft entwickeln kann über zwei, drei, vier Jahre. Das hat ja in Magdeburg auch so getan, da kann Thomas viel besser darüber berichten als ich. Aber ähnlich wie Quasnöck in Paderborn ist zum Beispiel, man macht da zwei, drei Jahre und dann ist die Mannschaft irgendwann auf diesem Peak und das scheint ja hier jetzt direkt zu funktionieren. Das kann auch ein Glückstreffer sein einfach, weil es in der Chemie von Anfang an passt, in einem Trainingslager, wie auch immer. Es hatte Paderborn zum Beispiel– ich weiß, ich rede immer viel über Paderborn, aber das ist halt das Team, wo ich am meisten weiß, als die diese Trainingsreise, das Trainingslager in den USA hatten, sind die da wie ausgewechselt zurückgekommen und haben aus einem Guss aufgespielt, kein Vorbereitungsspiel verloren und auch gut gestartet. Und das wirkt jetzt hier gerade auch so. Deswegen ist für mich Hannover 96 schon auch der Gewinner in diesem Transferfenster, die haben es sehr klug genutzt, sich auch hier und da verjüngt. Habe ich ja vorhin schon gesagt, auf der Torwartposition. Es klingt immer so, es ist gar nicht so gemeint, aber Altlast, also Zieler ist halt altes Hannover 96. Man kennt ihn sogar noch aus Zeiten, wo man deutlich höher in anderen Wettbewerben gespielt hat. Wann Mirko Slomka vielleicht auch noch Trainer war. Ganz lange her. Und deswegen ist es vielleicht auch mal gut, dass man jetzt mal wirklich einen Neustart nach einigen Jahren mit manchen Spielern auch noch geschafft hat. Und der neue Trainer plus das Staff drum herum vielleicht auch eine ruhige Saison fahren können. Auch mit einem Martin Kind und Co. im Rücken, der natürlich jetzt gerade nichts sagt.
Thomas, wenn du auf Hannover guckst, ich weiß, ich leg jetzt noch mal den Finger ein bisschen in die Wunde, aber überrascht dich das ein bisschen oder sagst du, ihr habt jetzt alle da unterschätzt, wie schnell der da auch eine Mannschaft zusammenkriegen kann.
Beides tatsächlich. Ich muss sagen, ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass mit diesem Komplett-Austausch, mehr oder weniger dieses Grades, dass das so schnell funktioniert, hätte ich auch so nicht erwartet. Kevin hat gerade gesagt, dass Christian Tietz durchaus in der Lage ist, eine Mannschaft auch spielerisch zu seiner Idee hinzuentwickeln und dass das dann auch gut funktionieren kann. Das haben wir in Magdeburg erleben dürfen. Wobei ich aber sagen muss, ich habe das Spiel gegen uns ja gesehen. Ich muss sagen, ohne da jetzt auch die FCM-Brille aufzusetzen, dieses Spiel dürfen wir nicht verlieren gegen Hannover. Normalerweise gehst du da mindestens mit einem Punkt vom Platz, kannst aber nichts machen, hast das Spiel im Griff, kriegst dann durch einen Torwart-Fehler das 0-1. Dann lässt ein Torjäger, der dann vier Tage später den Verein verlässt, in meinen Augen 200% geliegen. Ja, dann mal gucken, wie es dann ist. Wenn du dann selber 1-0 führst oder innerhalb von vier Minuten aus 0-2-2-2 machst, möchte ich gerne mal sehen, wie diese Hannoveraner Mannschaft dann reagiert. Kamen leider nicht so. Sie haben dann die Tore entsprechend zu den richtigen Zeitpunkten gemacht. Sie haben das Glück gehabt, dass die Gegentore nicht fielen. Gewinnen dann auch völlig verdient 3 zu 1. Um Gottes Willen möchte ich überhaupt nicht absprechen. Aber ich finde schon, gegen uns hat man schon gesehen, wir kennen ja auch Christian Tietz seinen Fußball, wo man diesen Fußball auch sehr extrem verwunden kann. Und das werden andere Mannschaften auch noch finden, gerade auch Mannschaften mit einer höheren individuellen Qualität, werden auch Hannover vor Aufgaben stellen. Und von daher bin ich da noch nicht so optimistisch, was das Thema Hannover 96 angeht, weil wir haben auch erlebt, es kann auch durchaus passieren, dass Christian Tietz mit seiner Mannschaft mal 7, 8 Spiele nicht gewinnt. Das haben wir hier in Magdeburg auch erleben dürfen. Und dann eben auch keine Planänderung innerhalb der Spielidee erfolgt. Also von daher bin ich da auch sehr gespannt, wie sich das da weiterentwickelt in Hannover. Klar, der Saisonsport ist natürlich absolut gelungen. 4 Spiele, 12 Punkte. Besser geht es nicht. Dabei auch nur zwei Gegentore. Das wundert mich auch ein bisschen. Auf einmal entdeckt auch der Trainer Christian Tietz, dass Standards vielleicht in einem Fußballspiel doch was bringen könnten. Hannover erzielt Tore nach Standardsituationen. Das war bei uns auch so ein Thema. Ich war überraschend, dass das auf einmal funktioniert. Schauen wir mal, aber grundsätzlich gebe ich Kevin da recht. So wie Hannover da gestartet ist, muss man schon sagen, Hut ab. Gerade auch mit dem ganzen Personal-Karussell, das da gefahren wurde. Aber ich bin wirklich gespannt, was dort passiert, wenn es mal eine Serie gibt, wo man 4, 5 Spiele mal nicht gewinnt. Wie dann das Umfeld reagiert, wie kommt dann doch Unruhe rein? Ob man da vielleicht dann doch keinen 3-Jahresplan will, oder vielleicht dann doch jetzt gleich hoch? Also warten wir mal ab, es sind 4 Spiele gespielt. Ich traue dem Braten da auch noch nicht so ganz.
Obwohl Martin Kind jetzt, glaube ich, im Punkt gesagt hat, es hätte nie einen 3-Jahresplan gegeben. Ich weiß manchmal nicht, ob er andere Menschen eins dumm verkaufen will, aber gut. Ja, Kevin, sagst du gerne erst.
Was ich immer wichtig finde, du hast ja viele wichtige Punkte gesagt, das ist nicht 100 Prozent überzeugend, war vielleicht in dem Spiel gegen euch zum Beispiel. Wenn du aber diese Spiele gewinnst, mit einer jungen, neu zusammengewürfelten Mannschaft, das schweißt die so schnell zusammen. Also wenn die die jetzt gegen euch verloren hätten oder einen Punkt geholt hätten, bin ich bei dir, dann kann dieser Schritt wieder zurückgehen und die kriegen eine Delle und dann ist der Saisonverlauf ein ganz anderer. Ich glaube aber, dass du dadurch echt viele Monate überspringen kannst, wo sich eine Mannschaft normalerweise so finden muss. Und gerade deswegen, glaube ich, haben sie klug eingekauft, weil sie offenbar dann nicht nur auf die Namen geguckt haben, also wie Trizoldi oder Co., die sie halt dann verkauft haben, sondern weil sie ein bisschen auch nach, naja, passt das? Also so unterstelle ich jetzt, ich bin kein Hannover 690 Experte, gerne ergänzen, wenn das jemand besser weiß, aber dass sie mehr auf die Eigenschaften, wie passen die menschlich zusammen vielleicht auch geguckt haben. So würde ich mir das erklären, weil sonst finde ich es echt schwierig zu erklären, dass eine Mannschaft so zündet. Also vier Siege, das ist schon sehr selten.
Ich glaube, es hat tatsächlich viel damit zu tun, dass es halt eben nicht so sechs, sieben Spieler waren, die neu dazugekommen sind, sondern dann eben doch viel. Und dann ist es natürlich auch so, dass ich dann ja so ein Gefüge auch vielleicht manchmal doch schneller finde, weil man so dann eben zusammen irgendwie auch nach einer neuen Achse sucht, nach neuen Führungspersönlichkeiten. Und ja, gleichzeitig eben auch so, das hat Tits ja auch öfter mal betont, dass eben der Kern, also ein Großteil dieses Kader stand eben enorm schnell schon. Und ich glaube, das darf man eben nie unterschätzen. Also sie waren eben nicht vielleicht andere Vereine doch noch mal darauf angewiesen, bis zum Ende des Transferfensters zu warten, was überhaupt finanziell machbar ist.
Das stimmt, ja.
Und also wenn man zum Beispiel immer auf die Innenverteidigung guckt, dass zum Beispiel auch was gemeinsam mit dem Torhüter, der eben das komplett neu ist. Also du hast mit Neu jemanden, der ja sicherlich auch einen Trainer braucht, der ihn da unterstützt. Also ich erinnere mich eigentlich noch ganz gut an diese Sache von einem Jahr circa, als er damals noch bei Viert im Tor stand und eben diese Geschichte auch mit Alex Zorniger, wo du, glaube ich, auch schon merkst, du brauchst auch irgendwie einen Trainer, der ihn dann natürlich vielleicht auch schon die Chance gibt, ihn aber gleichzeitig auch schützt. Und dann hast du eben so eine Dreierkette mit zwei Spielern, die, glaube ich, die 2. Liga eben noch gar nicht kennen, mit Gita und O'Conn, aber eben unterschiedliche, unterschiedlich viele Erfahrungen auch mitbringen. Und dann hast du aber Zentrale in der Mitte, Boris Tomiak. Der kennt die 2. Liga super. Der ist ein absoluter All-Star, könnte man auch sagen, in der 2. Liga. Der weiß, wie das geht. Und das scheint halt eben zu klappen. Gleichzeitig, also ich würde dir so ein bisschen widersprechen, Thomas. Ich glaube nämlich, weil dieser Kader ist ja noch nicht an seinem Limit. Also du hast ja einzelne Spieler, ich glaube wie Bundu, wie Pichla, die ja zum Beispiel selber noch gar nicht getroffen haben, die noch gar nicht ihre 100 Prozent gemacht haben. Und gleichzeitig funktioniert das halt mit den Jokern enorm gut. Also Kellmann, der dann, ich glaube, 3 Mal reinkommt, 3 Mal einen Jokertor erzielt. Und generell fand ich es auch ganz interessant. Also es wurde bisher ein geben Ligaspiel aus seinem Pokal, das einzige Spiel, das man verloren hat, das gesamte Wechselkontingent mit fünf Spielern genutzt. Und 17 von den 20 Spielern waren neu in Zugänge. Ja, es ist nicht schwierig, wenn sowieso gefühlt der halbe Kader aus 90 Klingen besteht. Aber das fand ich auch irgendwie relativ interessant. Deshalb…
Ja, aber auch das ist ja… Ja, sorry. Aber auch das ist ja eine interessante Parallele auch zu uns. Kann mich da sehr gut erinnern, denn letzte Saison, als wir Songstatt hatten, sind wir ja auch sehr, sehr gut gestartet und hatten auch… Da hatte Christian Tietz das Händchen, dass die Einwechsespieler dann auch immer getroffen haben. Also ich glaube, wir haben in den ersten zehn Spielen neun Joker-Tore gemacht. Letzte Saison, wenn ich das richtig in der Haufe habe. Das schlief dann zum Saisonende aber ganz schön ein, als es dann darum ging, die Punkte zu holen, die dann geholt werden mussten. Von daher… Ich warte da noch ein bisschen ab, weil ich habe es ja hier leiblich erleben dürfen, wie das ist, wenn man es dann eben nicht schafft. Und von daher, mal gucken. Machen wir uns aber nichts vor. Hannover hat natürlich– Christian Thies hat natürlich in Hannover auch ganz andere Rahmenvoraussetzungen als bei uns hier in Magdeburg. Und ich glaube, auch allein das ist schon ein Grund, die das natürlich auch nochmal in Hannover auch nochmal alles beschleunigen könnten. Ja, also gerade dieses ganze Thema Trainingsumfeld, etc., pp., dann ist alles, ich glaube auch, etat, der ist auch höher. Er kann ganz andere Spieler verpflichten, ganz andere Gehälter können dort gezahlt werden als hier bei uns. Also, schauen wir mal. Und ich glaube auch, ich sehe es wie Kevin. Also, ich denke auch, Hannover wird auf jeden Fall bis zum Saisonende oben dabei sein. Das sehe ich ganz genauso. Die Frage ist dann, ob es am Ende für den ganz großen Wurf reichen wird. Ja, aber wir haben schon viel richtig gemacht im Sommer, keine Frage.
Man muss eben noch auch sagen, also in dieser doch immer engen Liga haben sie jetzt eben schon vier Punkte Vorsprung auf Platz 4. Das heißt auch noch nichts zu Beginn der Saison. Das kann noch wichtig werden. Das kann aber komplett nichtig gemacht werden. Das wissen wir alle. Wir haben alle irgendwie dafür zu lange die 2. Liga schon so verfolgt eben und haben das mitgemacht. Aber ich glaube, generell ist es für den Standort Hannover einfach wichtig, da reinzumachen. Eine Ergänzung noch, weil Kevin auch einmal kurz die Bilanz angesprochen hat. Also es sind eben, stand jetzt, was heißt stand jetzt, es sind 5 Millionen plus in diesem Transfer-Saldo. Man muss eben aber auch sagen, da stand da immer ein Ticket vom Kicker, glaube ich. Da heißt es eben, sie zahlen halt deutlich höhere Gehälter. Das kommt in diesem Transfer-Saldo nicht mit rein. Aber man zahlt wohl deutlich höhere Gehälter als in der Vergangenheit. Und hat aber eben auch langfristigere Verträge. Also das deutet dann auch schon darauf hin, dass man es sich dann aber vielleicht eben nicht noch ein, zwei Jahre mehr leisten könnte, eben in der 2. Liga zu spielen bzw. nicht mit dem Kader dann. Also da sollte man dann doch auch das Ziel Erstklassigkeit erreichen. Und das darf man da, glaube ich, nie vergessen. Also nur weil vielleicht in einem Team keine, weiß ich nicht, 15 Millionen rausgibt, bedeutet das halt nicht, dass die Kosten für die Kader so viel geringer sind. Also man könnte jetzt bestimmt auch, wie Max das in der Bundesliga immer macht, mit diesen Wirtschaftsausgaben. Ich muss einfach sagen, ich kenne mich dazu wenig zu Iris und würde mich dann in irgendwelchen Zahlen verlieren. Daher entschuldigt mich nicht, dass ich das nicht mache. Aber das darf man eben auch da im Hintergrund nicht vergessen. Also ich glaube, der Druck ist eben trotzdem da. Und das würde wiederum doch deine These unterstützen, Thomas. Das ist dann natürlich auch, dass man eben noch nicht weiß, was passiert mal. Wenn sie dann vielleicht nicht ein Spiel verlieren, sondern ein paar mehr und die Leistungen dann vielleicht erst mal nicht mehr so stimmen. Da hast du natürlich auch recht, ja.
Plus, jetzt können sie noch vier Spiele auf einmal verletzen, alles Mögliche. Fakt ist, jetzt haben sie erst mal, glaube ich, gut die Mannschaft verstärkt oder erneuert. Sie sind im Schnitt ungefähr zwei Jahre jünger geworden im Team. Das ist ja auch nochmal ein wichtiger Punkt. Das heißt, Perspektive ist wieder– also, vorher waren sie mit 25 Jahren im Schnitt, was ja jetzt auch nicht alt ist. Aber es ist halt jetzt bei 23, und das habe ich gesehen, 23,5. Genau, also das ist ja auch nochmal– sie haben es einfach verjüngt. Und das ist, glaube ich, einfach nochmal junger, hungriger Spieler, ja, mit höheren Geldern. Das kann sicherlich durchaus auch sein, wenn man sieht, dass sie auch jemanden aus Portsmouths, nicht aus Portsmouths, sondern sie haben ja doch eine Primis. Primis, ne? Primis, also England, da verdient man wahrscheinlich noch mehr eigentlich. Also wenn sie da Spieler herholen und natürlich auch von Bundesliga-Absteigern, Kiel und Co., ja, gucken wir mal. Also wie gesagt, das Abwarten ist ja auch richtig von Thomas. Jetzt ging es ja erstmal darum, vermeintlich zumindest, scheinen sie im Sommer sehr gute Transferaktivitäten vorzugen zu haben.
Dann lass doch einmal gucken, Thomas, du wolltest dich nicht so ganz festlegen auf einen Verein. Hast du denn trotzdem irgendwie sowas, wo du sagst, okay, da wurde einfach schon clever investiert, da wird oder vielleicht eben auch nicht zu viel Geld in die Hand genommen. Hast du da so einen Verein, wo du sagst, ach, das all in all passt da schon?
Ja, ich würde fast Darmstadt tatsächlich nennen wollen. Die sieht man ja auch. Da konnte jetzt Florian Kohfeldt auch mal eine komplette Vorbereitung selber machen und konnte sich so ein bisschen auch den Kader hinbauen, wie er das wollte. Ich habe mit Patrick Pfeiffer, glaube ich, einen sehr, sehr wichtigen Spieler für Darmstadt zurückgeholt, der in Augsburg dann nicht so unter Bundesliga gezündet hat. Bei uns leider auch nicht ausgeliehen gewesen und ist jetzt von Augsburg zurück nach Darmstadt. Und ich glaube, der ist für Darmstadt sehr, sehr wichtig. War ja da auch, glaube ich, im Aufstiegsjahr, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, auch Kapitän. Als sie vor zwei, drei Jahren aufgestiegen sind, war Kapitän dort. Also ich glaube, die haben auch so ein bisschen unterm Radar. Ich glaube, am lautesten haben sie auch, haben wir, glaube ich, alle geschrien, oh, was macht ein Hertha da? Und was macht ein Hannover da aufgrund dieser extremen Personalfluktuation? Aber ich finde, Darmstadt ist da so ein bisschen auch unterm Radar gelaufen und hat sich da eigentlich, finde ich, eine gute Mannschaft hingebaut, die ja wahrscheinlich nicht aufsteigen wird, aber die auf jeden Fall auch eine gute Rolle in dieser Liga spielen wird oder kann und in meiner Meinung auch wird. Ich denke, das passt da ganz gut.
Ja, und tatsächlich könnte man ja auch ergänzen, wenn man auch fragt, wen mussten sie eigentlich nicht abgeben? Es ist halt Liedberg, ne? Also da war ja eben auch die große Diskussion, müssen sie ihn vielleicht am Ende verkaufen, will er gehen? Und das tut er eben nicht. Und ich glaube, das ist einfach was, was für Darmstadt ganz, ganz wichtig ist. Und was sie eben ja auch weiter nach vorne bringen wird. Also ich weiß, dass ich hier immer wieder sage, ich weiß immer noch nicht zu 100 Prozent, was Kohfeldts Plan mit Darmstadt ist. Aber auf der anderen Seite muss man ja auch fast sagen, das spricht halt in komischer Art und Weise natürlich auch für ihn, weil er eben dadurch eben nicht dieses eine System hat, was man eben vielleicht schneller ausklügeln kann. Aber du hast natürlich total recht. Also ich sehe sie eben auch nicht als Ausstiegskandidat. Dafür fehlt mir da doch was zu viel. Aber man muss gleichzeitig auch sagen, sie haben natürlich trotzdem die Möglichkeit, nach oben andere Teams immer wieder zu ärgern. Man hat gegen Bochum ganz am Anfang gesehen, was sie durchaus auch können, auch offensiv. Und da bin ich durchaus gespannt, ob das vielleicht eben, weil sie vielleicht am Ende des Tages halt einen Stürmer haben, der die Dinge halt macht. Also so blöd, wie es klingt. Aber manchmal reicht das vor allem auch, oder 2. Liga ganz gut. Also, Tirodda einfach mal als Beispiel genommen. Der stand dann einfach immer zum richtigen Zeitpunkt, am richtigen Ort. Und das hat seinen Verein immer wieder auch gut geholfen. Und ich glaube, er bringt da halt einfach nochmal andere Qualitäten mit. Und von daher, ja, hatte ich tatsächlich so gar nicht auf dem Schirm, aber enorm guter Pick. Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob du sonst noch jeden Verein hast. Vielleicht magst du sonst noch ein, zwei Sätze über deinen eigenen Club verlieren, über Magdeburg, vielleicht was dir da gefallen hat im Transferfenster, was vielleicht auch nicht?
Ja, war halt natürlich alles ein bisschen schwieriger aufgrund der Trainer-Situation, die uns Herr Zietzter hinterlassen hat mit dem ganzen Hin und Her und diesem Hingehalten und bla bla bla. Hat ja Otmar Schork auch gesagt, wir haben vier, fünf Wochen auf dem Transfermarkt verloren. Von daher, ich habe am Anfang gesagt, ich sehe das wie Kevin mit der Thematik, dass die Transferphase vorbei sein sollte, wenn die Saison losgeht. Andererseits muss ich sagen, haben wir natürlich in dieser Saison schon gut davon profitiert, dass es eben nicht so ist. Weil man eben mit Hürmerlein, mit Ryan Grieb zwei absolute Top-Leute, finde ich, geholt hat für unsere Mannschaft. Und das ist eben alles passiert, nachdem die Saison schon lief. Von daher haben wir da, glaube ich, diesmal ganz gut davon profitieren können. Aber grundsätzlich muss ich sagen, bin ich mit der Transferperiode unter den Bedingungen, die wir hier in Magdeburg hatten, sehr zufrieden. Wir haben, wie gesagt, mit Grieb und Thürmerle zwei Stammspieler geholt, die auch ihre Rolle spielen. Und Ryan Grieb hat ja, glaube ich, auch schon für ein bisschen Eindruck sorgen können, gerade auch im Pokal mit seinen zwei wunderschönen Toren da gegen Saarbrücken. Und jetzt, was jetzt noch passiert ist, hat man ja noch einen Japaner geholt. Mir fällt der Name leider gerade nicht ein. Wo man auch gesehen hat, mit dem Abgang von Martijn Kars, der natürlich schon sportlich gesehen auch wehtut, keine Frage. Aber ich finde, mich persönlich hat auch dieses ganze Theater da und hin und her und gehe ich, gehe ich nicht. Ja, jetzt ist er weg. Schön. Freut mich für ihn, dass er den Sprechen in die Bundesliga machen konnte. Uns hat es noch mal ein paar Millionen gebracht, die jetzt auch ein bisschen refinanziert wurden. Von daher, ja, sei es drum. Al Holmes drüben hat gegen Fürth jetzt gezeigt, dass er durchaus ein Stürmer in dieser Liga sein kann. Von daher tut mir dieser Abgang Kars gar nicht so weh, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Ich bin zufrieden. Ich denke auch, dass das mit Markus Fiedler hier im Laufe der Saison noch sehr, sehr gut funktionieren wird.
Ja, finde ich sehr beeindruckend, ehrlich gesagt, wie viel Ruhe man einfach von dir gerade vermittelt bekommt. Du sagst, ich bin da einfach noch positiv gestimmt. Und ich glaube, dass den Vorteil hat, man sich in Magdeburg auch einfach erarbeitet. Also diese vielleicht eben nicht direkt mit großem Chaos irgendwie in die Saison starten, sondern eben auch einfach das im Kontext sehen. Und da habe ich das Gefühl, da hatte man den Vorteil auf jeden Fall sehr vor Nürnberg, vor Hertha, vor Düsseldorf am Anfang auch. Dass in Magdeburg jetzt noch niemand groß geschrien hat, hey komm, nee, hier, wir müssen jetzt alles ändern. Das finde ich mir sehr bemerkenswert tatsächlich.
Ja, das ist auch, glaube ich, Ortmannschaug auch geschuldet, muss man ganz klar sagen. Also da ist hier Ruhe. Hier hat keiner geschrien nach einem fünften Platz, der auch durch andere Umstände in Meinung zu zustande gekommen ist. Normal dürfen wir nie fünfter werden, letzte Saison ist einfach so. Und das hat hier keinen zum Abheben gebracht. Also es gibt ja Vereine, die werden jetzt durchgedreht, hätten gesagt, Mensch, wir waren jetzt so nah dran. Hier sagt man, klar, wir würden schon gerne wieder da oben mitspielen, aber sagt auch ganz klar, Leute, lasst mal die Füße am Boden. Wir spielen jetzt das vierte Jahr am Stück 2. Liga, lasst uns mal erst mal die Klasse halten und dann gucken wir weiter.
Ich bin ja echt gespannt bei euch. Also ihr habt echt eine verhältnismäßig geringe Fluktuation gehabt. Also ein paar wichtige Spieler, aber in der Masse nicht so viele.
Im Prinzip Karzwerk, Burcu war geliehen, das war klar, dass der weggeht, also das war erwartbar. Elan Kuri hatte sich auch schnell angedeutet, aber der ist in meiner Meinung auch schon ersetzt. Also das ist, ob der jetzt weg ist oder nicht. Ich finde, mit Hürmulein hat man da einen richtig guten Transfer getätigt. Wie gesagt, Karz, ja, muss man gucken, wie man die 19 Tore auffangen kann, ob das den Al-Holmströmen jetzt schafft und auch unser Japaner, den wir da jetzt geholt haben. Aber grundsätzlich hast du recht, Kevin, wir haben zwei Leistungsträger verloren, drei, sagen wir mal drei, die hat man in meiner Meinung gut bis sehr gut ersetzt, vor allem durch Spieler. Ich finde, Grieb ist ein Spielertyp, der ist halt da. Also der ist verpflichtet und der ist da. Der braucht kein halbes Jahr, um sich einzugewöhnen, der ist da. Und genau solche Spieler haben wir jetzt noch gebraucht und da haben wir mit den Neuzügigen, die ich jetzt gesagt habe, auf jeden Fall welche geholt. Ja, ich bin da sehr, sehr hoffnungsfroh und freue mich auf den Rest der Saison.
Und alle relativ junge.
Ja, und man muss natürlich auch sagen, also man hatte ganz am Anfang dieses Braunschweig-Spiel, wo man eigentlich sagen muss, auch wie beim Hannover-Spiel, also aus anderen Umständen, aber das sind eigentlich zwei Spiele, die du aus unterschiedlichen Gründen so wahrscheinlich nicht verlieren darfst, einfach weil du gegen Braunschweig in Überzahl warst. Und ich meine, ist halt ein Sonntagsschuss am Ende, könnte dann einfach diskutieren, man muss halt früher einfach das eigene Tor machen. Ich glaube, dann kommt Braunschweig da auch nicht mehr raus wahrscheinlich. Und eben was du zu Hannover hast, du ja eben schon gesagt. Also ich glaube, sobald sich da vielleicht auch einfach die Spielverläufe ändern, sehen wir eh bei Mark Tobukens andere Ergebnisse eben hinten raus. Und das ist natürlich auch, wenn du halt so jemanden wie Tietz hast, der den Verein einfach auf dem Platz geprägt hat. Das ist natürlich auch eine gewaltige Aufgabe für den Trainer, das eben auch wieder umzuändern. Und man muss ja trotzdem sagen, dass Markus Schiedler da ja glaube ich schon so anfängt, eben seine Akzente zu setzen. Und eben wie du sagst, man kennt es eben in Magdeburg, dass sich so eine Mannschaft auch entwickeln muss. Also und dass da die Geduld eben jetzt auch da ist. Ich glaube, es wäre schon anders gelaufen, wäre es jetzt eben nochmal eine Saison unter Tietz gewesen und man wäre so gestartet. Ich weiß nicht, ob du mir dazu stimmen würdest generell, dass es halt da andere Vorzeichen gewesen wären. Aber so ist halt eh einem im Verein klar, das braucht halt einfach kurz, weil viele halt auch einfach die 2. Liga noch nicht kennen.
Genau. Ja, das sehen wir alle so. Also zumindest mit den Leuten, mit denen ich spreche.
Ja, wie gesagt, also muss ich sagen, finde ich bemerkenswert, weil es eben im Fußball-Business doch nicht immer, also ganz liebe Grüße an Leverkusen.
Der war jetzt böse.
Ey, ich darf das aus dem Zeusel mal. Die Erlaubnis gebe ich mir einfach mal selber, weil ich vor allem jetzt zu einem Verein wechsle, wo ich selber in der Saison Prognose mehr oder weniger gesagt habe, ja, okay, Transfers, ja, aber glaube, das wird nicht klappen, auch mit dem Trainer nicht. Und das ist Preußen Münster. Ich musste, habe vor zwei Wochen schon mal gesagt, ich muss mich ein bisschen korrigieren und ich muss mich jetzt immer mehr korrigieren, ehrlich gesagt. Also es ist natürlich, also sie als Gewinner auf dem Transfermarkt zu bezeichnen, kommt vielleicht ein bisschen wild. Sie haben eben mit 1,7 Millionen, das ist eben das Geld, was sie investiert haben. Es ist gleichzeitig eben der negative Transfersaldo, weil sie nichts eingenommen haben. Und man muss eben noch dazu sagen, ihr Haupteinkauf, also Antonio Tickvich mit 700.000 Euro, der hat sich ja am ersten Spieltag durch den Foul direkt wieder verletzt. Der hat einen Kreuzbandriss, wird voraussichtlich bis März fehlen. Und sonst muss ich aber einfach sagen, man spricht da nicht drüber, weil sie brutal, also sich brutal gut verstärkt haben und eben größtenteils dann doch ablösefreie Spieler geholt haben. Sie haben mit Paul Jeckel jemanden für die Innenverteidigung geholt, der einfach brutal wichtig ist, der seine Qualität zeigt und sie haben eben ein festes Spielsystem. Also ich hatte zum Teil das Problem unter Hildmann war auch irgendwann, dass die Problematik eben, dass es immer wieder ein Wechsel gab zwischen so einem 3-4-2-1 und 4-2-3-1 und bla und dann ist natürlich auch irgendwann schwierig, für diese Systeme Spiele einzukaufen und unter Alexander Enne ist das halt relativ klar. Es ist ein 4-4-2 mit Raute, was er eigentlich spielen lassen will. Das machte er seit er bei von Thuner Köln Coach war, von 2020 bis 2022 und da muss ich einfach sagen Respekt. Also sie spielen auch einfach richtig guten Fußball. Das muss man einfach nochmal dazu sagen. Sie haben eine Sicherheit, sie haben die höchste Passquote der Liga und also das ist schon beachtenswert ehrlich gesagt und das zeigt eben aber auch, Enne will ein sehr stabiles, ein kompaktes, ein dominierendes Mittelfeld und das funktioniert bisher sehr, sehr gut. Man ist eben auch in den Top 5 der Ballbesitzmannschaften. Da muss ich so ein kleines Sternchen versehen, weil also die Top Ballbesitzmannschaft hat 55 Prozent mit Dynamo Dresden. Das ist halt Anfang der Saison. Man könnte sagen, es will halt wirklich niemand den Ball haben oder äußerst wenige Mannschaften, aber man hat eben auch schon zwei Spiele, wo man 70 Prozent hatte, jetzt eben auch zuletzt gegen Bochum. Von daher, das ist schon da. Also viele reden eben über Hannover und wie das mit Hitz funktioniert. Aber ich muss auch etwas sagen. Alexander Inder hat mich so doch überrascht. Also ich meine, ich habe ihn bei fair gesehen und das hat mich tatsächlich trotz allem nicht komplett vom Hocker gehauen. Aber scheint so, dass er mit der Qualität, die er in der 2. Liga als Trainer dann zur Verfügung hat, doch ehrlich gesagt nochmal. Weil, ja, einfach mehr mitbringt. Also ich weiß nicht, Kevin, vielleicht mal die Frage an dich. Überrascht dich das vielleicht auch. Wir haben ja einfach die Distanz, nicht die Distanz, sondern die örtliche Nähe zu preusen. Wie siehst du das?
Erstmal noch ein Sternchen. Am 2. Spieltag haben wir sie ja mit aufgebaut, nachdem sie ihren ersten Spieltag verloren haben. Wir haben dort unsere drei Punkte verschenkt und denen einen ersten Punkt geschenkt. Denen soll gar nicht so abfällig klingen, gemeint sein, wie es klingt. Da hätten wir in den letzten zehn Minuten noch zwei Tore schießen können müssen. Zum Beispiel Grimaldi. Aber da hätten wir vielleicht für den noch ein paar Euro mehr bekommen. Nein, also, ja, sie spielen, also, weiß ich nicht, also das Spiel war, ich habe nicht alle Spiele von ihnen gesehen. Das gegen Paderborn habe ich natürlich gesehen. Da waren sie in der ersten Halbzeit nicht so überzeugend. Da hat der SCP relativ verdient geführt zur Pause. Aber dann haben sie in der zweiten Halbzeit das, was du sagst, ganz gut umgesetzt. Also nicht so, wie man es vorher öfter mal hatte in der letzten Saison, dass sie dann auch wirklich relativ langweilig oder grau geblieben sind und das Ding maximal noch gesavet haben, so dass es nicht höher ausgeht oder so. Haben sie hier ganz gut ins Spiel gefunden. Und danach, die beiden Spiele, Bochum ist ja schon auch beachtlich, auch wenn Bochum natürlich einfach Schwierigkeiten hat zum Saisonstart, ist so. Trotzdem musst du in Bochum auch erstmal gewinnen. Find ich absolut, fand ich, war ein Ausrufbezeichen. Und sie haben ja auch am ersten Spieltag auch ganz spät nur verloren. Also das 3-2, bis dahin sah das ja auch ganz gut aus. Bin ich bei dir, sie wirken noch mal stabiler und von der Spiele Idee auch noch mal ein bisschen flexibler einfach, was das angeht, wenn sie den Rückstand geraten sollten, dass sie dann noch mal ein paar Optionen haben, ins Spiel zurückzukommen.
Ja und ich finde, ja.
Ob sie es noch sagen müssen, wenn sie aufgebaut haben.
Ja, ich finde halt einfach, also ist natürlich trotzdem auch da nicht so einfach, ne. Also nach dieser Niederlage, man muss ja sagen, es war eine Unterzahl, wenn ich mich jetzt richtig, nee, du warst in der Überzahl, Unterzahl. Ja, perfekt. Ich weiß selber nicht mehr, ich hab zu viel Schirmhalszüge.
Am ersten Spieltag.
Ja. Da waren sie in…
In Kreisruhe.
Jaja, aber waren sie da in Überzahl oder in Unterzahl?
Da waren sie in Unterzahl, da hast du recht.
Da waren sie in Unterzahl, ne? Haben die rote Gerade gesehen. Ich gucke so schnell.
So relativ früh, nach 62 Minuten.
Genau, genau. Da hatte ich doch… Also mein Kopf lässt mich doch nicht im Stich manchmal. Sehr gut. Ah, dass ich mir sowas merken kann, aber andere Dinge nicht. Das ist… Das ist das größere Problem. Ne, aber generell, also das meine ich einfach mit sonst generell, möchte ich noch mal generell sagen. Man muss eben sagen, sie haben einfach clever auch diesen Kader aufgebaut. Also Alexander Ender sagt selber, ich verlinke euch nachher auch noch ein Interview in den Show Notes. Das ist zwar Kicker Plus, vielleicht kommt ihr da ja irgendwie dran. Da sagt er eben auch für ihn was eben wichtig, jede Position doppelt zu besetzen, damit man da eben auch diese Flexibilität hat und generell einfach, ne, jeder Spieler eben weiß, wie das funktioniert. Und man muss eben sagen, man sieht von Spiel zu Spiel eben auch die Entwicklung. Und ich glaube, das ist schon beachtenswert. Wie gesagt, Alexander auch einer der Trainer, eben die Neuen in der 2. Liga sind. Man kann halt am Ende des Tages sagen, ich glaube, es sind ja insgesamt acht Trainer, die noch nie in der 2. Liga gecoacht haben. Und ja, vielleicht ist das auch am Ende Vorteil, weil eben dann doch da mehrere neue Trainer reinkommen und man sich dann vielleicht anders auch an die Liga anpassen kann. Aber ja, also was er sagt, wirkt eben auch sehr schlüssig. Er nimmt halt als Hauptkritikpunkt momentan noch das Pressing als Problemfeld. Also er sagt eben da, das funktioniert eben noch nicht so ganz. Und ich glaube, wenn sie das aber reinkriegen, dann werden sie halt auch mit dem Abstieg nichts zu tun haben. Und das finde ich schon bemerkenswert. Man muss halt auch einfach sagen, klar, nicht überbewerten, aber sieben Punkte aus für Spielen, das hatte man in der letzten Saison erst am zehnten Spieltag und den zweiten Sieg auch eben erst am elften Spieltag. Und eben diese Punkte, wenn man jetzt guckt, wo Nürnberg und Bochum stehen, klar. Aber trotzdem muss man ja sagen, du musst es auch erst mal schaffen, gegen diese Teams zu gewinnen. Und eben nicht nur, dass man im Spiel gegen Karlsruhe sagt oder in der zweiten Halbzeit gegen Paderborn sagt, ja, Ansätze waren gut. Ja, bringt dir halt am Ende nichts. Du musst halt die Punkte relativ flott dann doch holen. Und das finde ich durchaus bemerkenswert. Und dass man eben dann eine klare Transferstrategie dann verfolgt hat, die eben zu Alex Ende passt. Und man muss da auch sagen, ich glaube, Ende, der hatte eben schon im Frühjahr entschieden, er verlängert seinen Vertrag bei Vierling. Damals war aber logischerweise noch nicht klar, dass er zu Münster kommen soll, weil die Hildmann-Entlassung war ja viel später. Aber da wurde er eben auch gefragt, ob er auch zu Münster gekommen wäre, wären die in der dritten Liga abgestiegen. Er hat ja auch Münster an der Vergangenheit. Das hat er bejaht, also von daher durchaus beachtenswert. Ich glaube, wenn ihr da sonst mal mehr lesen wollt noch zu Preußen, das Preußen-Journal, sonst auch einfach noch mal reingucken. Ja, das wäre so mein Tipp gerade zu Preußen Münster.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr noch was sagen wollt.
Ja, gerne.
Ich glaube, er hat es auch klug gemacht, gerade als jemand, der neu in die Liga kommt, dass er zwei Spieler mitgebracht hat. Ich meine, das sollen wir ja angeblich nicht machen. Aber es hilft natürlich ihm ungemein, wenn die Spieler in der Kabine zwei von ihm sind, die aus Färl mitbringen, die innerhalb der Mannschaft dann einfach auch noch mal ihn platzieren können oder das Ganze einfach auch schon mitleben können, was er ja dort als Spiele-Diä auch schon hatte in Färl. Das ist einfach ein Joker, wenn du den ziehen kannst, solltest du es versuchen. Das hilft natürlich nicht immer, aber ich glaube schon, dass das ein Trainer schon auch was bringen kann, wenn er gewohnt ist. Jeder fühlt sich, glaube ich, wohl, wenn er ein Umfeld teilweise mitnehmen kann, wo er sich wohlgefühlt hat. Also wenn er sich nicht wohlgefühlt hat, dann vielleicht nicht, aber andersrum schon. Und ich glaube, in Färl war das schon ein guter Arbeitsplatz für ihn, ein gutes Sprungbrett. Und es sind auch noch zentraler Mittelfeldspieler dabei. Also jemand, der dann wirklich auch die Spiele, die er im Mittelfeld mitträgt. Plus hier der, wie heißt er denn, der Stürmer, ich komme da nie drauf. Ja, genau, danke. Der ist es, ja. Ja, also das ist ganz gut und beachtliche Verpflichtung, den Batista Mayer-Kentmayer noch aus Ulm.
Oder Dresden oder 80.000 anderen Vereinen.
Und dann noch sogar jemanden vom FC Watt fortgeholt und so weiter und so fort. Aber auch dann perspektivische Spieler, viele auch, die so im mittleren 20er bis hohen 20er-Bereich sind, also auch Erfahrungen haben. Ich glaube, das bin ich gespannt. Ich hatte das gar nicht so auf dem Schirm wie du jetzt. Finde ich echt einen interessanten Take. Ja, muss man mal im Auge behalten, wo sie das so hinführt. Spannend.
Am Ende war er, glaube ich, auch, als er dann geäußert hat, dass er in Färl dann aufhört im Frühjahr. Wenn ich mich da recht erinnere, war er auch sehr, sehr schnell auch ein Kandidat bei durchaus auch für die 2. Liga. Hat er schon auch in Färl, glaube ich, schon gute Arbeit geleistet und hat sich da auch schnell dann auch auf den Schirm gebracht von 2. Ligas und grundsätzlich finde ich es auch– wir haben ja so Schwerpunkt-Transfers– ich finde es auch eine schöne Entwicklung, dass acht neue Trainer in die Liga kommen. Ich finde, das ist einfach, das bringt auch mal frischen Wind rein. Das sind nicht immer die gleichen Gesichter, die irgendwo– ich sage das jetzt mal ein bisschen überspitzt– die bei fünf, sechs anderen Vereinen schon mit Anführungsstrichen gescheitert sind, sondern die einfach mal von unten hochkommen, die in der 3. Liga sich ihre Sporen verdient haben. Endlich auch ein Fiedler, der in der 3. Liga mit Stuttgart die Klasse mit der zweiten Mannschaft halten konnte. Paderborn ist sogar noch ein Schritt mutiger gewesen. In meiner Meinung nach holten U19-Trainer in die 2. Bundesliga aus Karlsruhe. Ich finde, es ist auch ein schöner Trend, der da gerade passiert, dass man eben auch mal neue Gesichter in die Liga holt und nicht immer die ganzen alten Säcke in die Vereine platziert, weil man denkt, das bringt jetzt irgendwas, bringt ja auch immer wieder mal neue Ideen mit rein, neue Ansätze. Entschuldigung, dass ich jetzt drauf komme, aber ich muss einfach sagen, ich finde einfach so auch kommunikativ der Unterschied zwischen Christian Tietz und Markus Fiedler, das sind Welten. Das sind Welten auf den Pressekonferenzen. Und auch da merkt man, das ist schön, dass da mal frischer Wind reinkommt und nicht immer die gleichen Phrasen zu hören sind, die man jahrelang gehört hat. Also es ist ein schöner Trend, der da passiert und das darf, wenn Trainer gewechselt werden, was natürlich in der letzten Saison schon auch sehr abenteuerlich auch phasenweise war. Aber dann ist das ja ein schöner Weg.
Was? Kaiserslautern?
Was?
Und man sieht ja schon, ich finde, man hat ja schon gesehen, es ist wirklich schön, dass wir diese Vereinigungen heute auch so besprechen. Auch Münster hat uns ja letzte Saison nach dem Trainerwechsel sehr, sehr wehgetan, mit einem sehr hohen Sieg hier bei uns. Und da hat man schon gesehen, was es dann eben doch auch mal bringen kann. Also es ist ja nicht immer so, dass diese Trainerwechsel, weil wir von außen meinen, wir können das jetzt beurteilen. Und das ist ja alles Mist, was da passiert. Also man sieht ja schon, dass diese Trainerwechsel dann, finde ich, auch in einer Häufigkeit auch was gebracht haben. Also wenn man das so sieht, wer da so gewechselt wurde, auch in Köln, als man da auf Funkel umgeschwungen ist, letzte Saison. Es hat halt letzten Endes gefruchtet. Die Spiele unter Schruber waren katastrophal. Also ich habe das Spiel in Regensburg gesehen und der Wechsel war nötig. Und ich finde aber, dass man jetzt so diesen Weg geht und sagt, Mensch, in der 2. Liga, wir sind eben nicht eine Ausbildungsliga für Spieler, sondern wir holen jetzt auch mal junge Trainer in die Liga, finde ich, ist ein schöner Trend und das darf gerne so weitergehen, wenn man meint, man muss Trainer wechseln. Also natürlich hälte man jetzt nicht, um junge Trainer reinzuholen, immer den Trainer wechseln. Auch wenn man dann den Trainer wechselt, finde ich schön, dass man diesen Weg jetzt so geht und sagt, Mensch, da sind Spieler, die haben sich in der 3. Liga ihre Sporen verdient oder auch im Jugendfußball. Warum denen nicht mal eine Chance geben?
Finde ich super.
Ja, und wie du gerade sagst, sprich natürlich auch für die 3. Liga. Also dass du halt mit Alex Ende, mit Knier, mit Thomas Stamm, der ja auch die– nicht, ich sage immer Thomas Stamm. Doch, das passt. Thomas Stamm passt. Ich habe letztes Mal den Versprecher Thomas Mann drin. Das ist ein anderer. Und so natürlich auch Trainer hast du eben noch nicht lange. Auch einfach, also du hast natürlich auch die Beispiele von Trainern, die dann aus der 3. Liga hochkommen. Und man kennt sie trotzdem als Namen schon. Aber wie du eben sagst, das sind eben auch neue Namen. Eben auch ein Muslitsch bei Schalke und so, das einfach zu passen scheint. Und du siehst eben gleichzeitig bei anderen Vereinen, Stichwort VfL Bochum. Das ist halt, vielleicht hätten sie den Trainerwechsel machen müssen und da neuen Wind reinbringen. Man weiß es immer nicht. Aber ja, auf jeden Fall guter Punkt. Und ich glaube, das ist auch einfach, ja, wie du eben sagst, wenn du jetzt, ich bringe einmal kurz das Beispiel Leverkusen rein, aber wenn du da halt hörst, wer da schon wieder kursiert, die können sich halt meistens, sage ich mal, auch diese Risiken nicht erlauben. Also in der Bundesliga ist die Fallhöhe natürlich auch viel höher, dann zu sagen, ach, wir nehmen den. Also ich meine selbst, Kevin wird es wissen, selbst Köln mit Kwasniok, das kann, Paderborn war immer wieder Sprungbrett, sage ich mal in Anführungszeichen, das ist gar nicht dispektierlich gemeint, für Trainer, die es dann in der Bundesliga versucht haben, weil sie vielleicht…
Das hat ja ganz früh schon bei uns angefangen, mit Jules Lohokaj, das weiß man nicht. Dieter Hecking war bei uns Spieler.
Wir fangen jetzt nicht mit Schmieler an, ich glaube, dann sitzen wir noch drei Stunden.
Mitch Kniehart kommt übrigens auch aus dem Paderborn Nachwuchsleistungszentrum.
Ja, ich weiß, ich weiß. Ein noch, ein noch. Und der war entfernt, die ostasfälische, weiß ich nicht, Dreifaltigkeit, könnte man sagen.
Es ist ja eine Auszeichnung, ein Prädikat. Wertvoll wollte ich was sagen für die 2. Liga. Wenn das, was Thomas sagt, das ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt. Das meinte ich auch eingangs, dass diese Liga wirklich vom Level her so ist. Und das ist ja gar nicht schlimm, dass entweder gescheiterte Trainer, Spieler, Sportlichleiter, wer auch immer, oder halt Talente, das supergut nutzen können, auch vom Niveau her, dass es dann offenbar auch reicht. Also ich meine, Korsien hat jetzt einen guten Start erwischt. Klar, es hätte auch andersrum laufen können. In Köln zum Beispiel. Baumgart ist auch immer noch in der Bundesliga-Trainer und so weiter und so fort. Und es gibt ja tausend andere Beispiele. Also das ist schon spannend. Das macht Spaß. Und deswegen gucke ich halt die 2. Liga auch gerne, weil da viele, viele neue Gesichter auch auftauchen jede Saison.
Ja, und man muss, also nicht immer nur wegen des Fußballs. Da muss man glaube ich am Ende des Tages immer noch sagen, das ist vielleicht jetzt nicht der allerbeste der Welt, aber es macht natürlich trotzdem Spaß. Ich würde noch eine honorable Mention, aber ein negativer Sinne reinbringen, das ist der VfL-Buch, weil es wurde auch ein bisschen im Forum gefordert. Und jetzt ganz groß darauf einzugehen, heute machen wir das nochmal in den nächsten Wochen. Ich lege jetzt einfach die komplette Last um auf Mark. Ich finde das super. Aber da läuft es natürlich einfach nicht so gut zu Saisonstart. Ich glaube, das haben wir alle mitbekommen. Es gab eben diesen Sieg gegen Elbersberg, der natürlich auch viel mit der roten Garte zu tun hat. Und sonst eben drei Niederlagen gegen Darmstadt ganz zu Beginn. Dann gab es eben gegen Schalke die Niederlage und jetzt gegen Münster. Und aufgrund dessen hat eben auch das Präsidium, das generell auch neu formiert worden, haben einen Brief veröffentlicht und da unter anderem gesagt, die ersten Wochen hätten gezeigt, dass vor uns liegt viel Arbeit. Drei Niederlagen aus vielen Ligaspielen sprechen eine deutliche Sprache. Wir wissen, wie sehr euch das enttäuscht und auch verunsichert. Man habe deshalb genau hingeschaut und gemeinsam mit den Verantwortlichen intensive Gespräche geführt. Man will keine großen einschneidenden Sachen machen. Also keine– das klang jetzt noch nicht nach Trainerwechsel und Co. Das würde nur durch Zusammenhalt funktionieren und da mit Trainern, Spielern und restlichen Verantwortlichen. Man ist auf dem Transfermarkt aktiv geworden mit Alfa Ruprecht, noch jemanden für die rechte Außenbahn, mit Michael Oberfemin, einen zusätzlichen Mittelstürmer verpflichtet. Gerade Alfa Ruprecht könnte, glaube ich, extrem wichtig werden, weil das Flügelspiel bei Bochum bisher eine absolute Vollkatastrophe war. Ich glaube, das ist nicht untertrieben, wenn man das so ausdrückt. Also es war quasi vorhanden, liegt natürlich, dass mit Miochi auch ein Spieler für die rechte Außenbahn oder zumindest für das rechte Offensive Mittelfeld verletzt ist. Man hat eben auch aktuell 5 Verletzte mit Stromfko Cieszki, einer der Sisoko, Quateng und Miochi. Aber generell, man muss glaube ich vor allem sagen, viel zu einfache Gegentore, die dir so in der 2. Liga auch nicht passieren dürfen, vorne zu wenig gefährlich. Also man hat eigentlich gar nicht so viele, wenige Torschüsse abgegeben im Liga-Vergleich, aber eben daraus zu wenig gemacht. Und es fehlen glaube ich einfach komplett die Führungsspieler. Also Kevin Vogt war eine Idee, eine Idee, die bisher noch nicht so funktioniert hat. Das habe ich beim letzten Mal schon gesagt. Ich weiß nicht, wir müssen das jetzt nicht groß besprechen.
Du hast einen wichtigen Punkt vorher schon gesagt, bei den Trainern mit dem Ringsi-Korps, bei gestandenen Vereinen und so. Wie hat es das mit den Spielern gemacht? Hier sind so viele Spieler gekommen, die U-20 teilweise auch sind. VfL Bochum hat sehr krass verjüngt, was ja ein guter Ansatz so gesehen vielleicht ist. Aber ich bin bei dir, sie haben halt dann wirklich diese Last der Verantwortung oder der Erfahrung auf zwei, drei Schultern. Es sind vielleicht ein paar mehr. Aber zwei, drei Spieler hätte ich jetzt unter den Verpflichtungen, wie Soko Vogt. Und dann hört es bei mir schon fast auf. Strom vielleicht noch, wobei der aus Ulm kommt. Also es ist jetzt auch vielleicht nicht das Niveau, was du in Bochum hast, um direkt durchzustarten. Aber schwierig, sehr riskant. Sehr riskante Transferpolitik. Ist nicht der erste Absteiger, der so strauchelt nach dem Saisonstück. Das kann halt in acht Wochen irgendwann auch wieder ganz anders ausschlagen. Das ist einer der Kandidaten, wo ich deswegen nicht vorhin gesagt habe, wenn der erste Absteiger schlagen will, spiele ich am Anfang der Saison gegen sie, weil dann sind sie völlig noch da nieder. Ja, bin ich beide ja total auf Risiko gegangen, was die Transferpolitik angeht. Ja, spannend. Also da bin ich wirklich gespannt, wie sich das entwickelt. Zumal Kevin Vogt jetzt für mich auch nicht so der Player ist mit 33 aus Berlin von Union gekommen. Ja, weiß ich nicht. Ja, und du hast gesagt, ein Trainer ist vielleicht auch da. Ja, quasi. Ist spekulativ. Aber ich glaube, sie haben sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr wenig Erfahrungen dazu geholt. Also vor allem Erfahrungen in diesem harten 2. Liga-Geschäft, was es immer noch ist, wo alles sehr eng beieinander ist und wo es halt nicht so ist, dass Münz da nicht gewinnen kann, sondern die können das dann halt einfach, weil sie mehr Erfahrung auf den Platz bringen in dem Moment und vielleicht besser zu einem gewachsen sind auch schon. Thomas, du wolltest aber was sagen.
Ja, ja, das ist halt auch ein, also ich finde, das ist auch ein krasser Punkt, was du sagst mit den Verpflichtungen. Also, wir haben jetzt den Alpha-Rupik da von Leverkusen geholt. Man ist ja gut und schön, dass da ein 19-jähriges, scheinbar 19-jähriges Rose-Talent da ist. Aber man sagt ja nicht ohne Grund, dass junge Spieler sich am besten entwickeln, wenn sie in einer gewachsenen Hierarchie spielen, wo du ältere Spieler hast, die dich so ein bisschen führen. Das sehe ich in Bochum auch überhaupt nicht. Da schmeißt man jetzt ein paar junge Spieler rein, in der Hoffnung, dass das funktioniert. Gut, jetzt kann man natürlich sagen, du hast mit Dieter Hecking jetzt einen Trainer. Ja, der hat halt auch alles schon gesehen. Also dem machst du ja jetzt grundsätzlich auch erstmal nichts vor. Also der kann dir natürlich als jugendspieler dahingehend auch helfen. Das ist, glaube ich, was anderes, als wenn da jetzt ein Markus Fieler in dieser Situation wäre oder auch ein Trainer von Paula Born oder das wäre eine ganz andere Situation, glaube ich. Von daher glaube ich schon, dass Dieter Hecking da auch eine positive Rolle spielen kann. Aber so ein junger Kerl muss das natürlich auch erstmal alles annehmen, da in der 2. Liga. Das ist ja schon ein bisschen was anderes als Senioren-Bundesliga. Und es ist schön, mit 19 dann da hinzukommen. Aber da reden wir doch von Senioren-Fußball, nicht mehr von Jugend-Fußball. Das ist schon ein kleiner Unterschied. Und ich finde das auch ein sehr riskanter Weg, den man an Bochum geht. Ich bin echt gespannt, wie das da weitergeht. Aber ich glaube schon, dass die mit Dieter Hecking einen Trainer haben, der das da aus dem Dreck rauszieht, bin ich von überzeugt.
Ja, ich glaube einfach, ich weiß halt nicht, weil ich glaube, da liegt halt so viel im Argen, weil man eben diesen Abstieg hinter sich hat. Und man wollte halt, ich glaube, die Fans wollten halt vor allem Chris Gamboa und Toto Lissia da auch eben einen würdigen Abschied erweisen. Ich meine, Lissia ist jetzt im Trainerstab auch drin. Der hatte jetzt gestern, glaube ich, sein Abschiedsspiel. Vielleicht manchmal kann sowas ja auch helfen, um einfach so ein Verein noch mal näher zusammenwachsen zu lassen, indem man irgendwie eine absolute Vereinslegende auch feiert. Aber ich habe halt einfach das Gefühl, da ist eben nicht erst seit Anfang der Saison, sondern schon viel länger was im Argen. Und das hat, glaube ich, damals schon fast mit Peter Zeidler angefangen, wenn man da mal so ein bisschen zurückguckt, wenn man da auf die Transfers schaut, die da auch schon immer nicht glatt liefen. Ich glaube, dass das einfach ein Problem ist, was schon länger wächst. Und also, ich meine, Kevin, wir sind beide Fans von Vereinen, die es eben mitgemacht haben, was mal nach so einem Bundesliga-Abstieg passieren kann. Wenn du eben nicht dich nach einer Hälfte der Saison irgendwie wieder fängst. Also beide abgestiegen und dann eben schon fast auch sogar aus unterschiedlichen Gründen mal gerade an der Regionalliga vorbei gekratcht. Also, wie gesagt, aus unterschiedlichen Gründen. Aber also, das ist eben kein Selbstläufer hinten raus. Und klar, da ist– ich bin hier niemand, der öffentlich Training, Trainerentlassung fährt. Aber ich habe halt von Anfang an nicht so komplett verstanden, warum man so voreilig schon gesagt hat, man macht mit ihm weiter, anstatt sich in der Sommerpause vielleicht einfach mal fünf Tage zu nehmen und zu diskutieren. Was ist denn wirklich der beste Weg, vielleicht sogar Fan-Vertreter dazu zu holen, ne? Also, ohne das jetzt überspitzen zu können.
Die da Hedwig auch in eine andere Rolle stellen können, einfach übergeordnet. Also, das wäre für mich noch ein… Aber Thomas mag recht haben. Es kann natürlich auch so eine Art Papa-Figur für junge Spieler sein. Ich weiß nicht, ob das heutzutage bei so ganz jungen Spielern noch zieht. Aber das hat zum Beispiel bei Steffen Baumgart super funktioniert. Der war… Denn Sven Michel hat ihn mal der Alte genannt. Da hat es funktioniert. Aber ja, es kann schon ein positiver Punkt sein. Lass sie mal jetzt irgendwie eins dieser Spiele, was sie jetzt gegen Günther verloren haben, gewinnen. Und zwar genau andersrum irgendwie. Last-minute oder was weiß ich, mit einem Tor des Monats. Dann kann das so Typen wie Rupprecht und Co. natürlich auch pushen. Dann kann so ein Trainer vielleicht auch nochmal die jungen Spieler auch quasi mit viel Erfahrung nochmal dazu bringen, dass sie konstanter werden. Ich bin bei dir, Eva, du hast es ja gesagt, sie wirken sehr unkonzent... Also so wäre auch, dass sie noch gar kein richtiges Spielsystem verinnerlicht haben, sagen wir es mal so, um ein bisschen fachlich zu sprechen. Es ist sehr ungefestigt, sehr, sehr locker. Läufst du hier, läufst du da, läufst du da, nicht läufst du dorthin. Und wer hat noch nicht und wer übernimmt jetzt? Und das ist nicht zweitliger Niveau. Ich glaube, Thomas, das, was du gesagt hast, das ist noch mal was anderes als im jenüren Bereich. Dann einfach.
Genau. Wer sonst noch mehr zum VfL-Buch rumlesen will, da habe ich auch noch mal einen Artikel verlinkt vom 1848-Blog. Die haben auch einen Podcast. Also da sonst rein hören und rein lesen wäre mein Tipp. Und sonst würde ich diese Folge jetzt abschließen noch mit einer Runde Housekeeping. Ihr kennt es, der Rasenfunk ist und bleibt werbe-, paywall- und sponsorenfrei. Er finanziert sich ausschließlich durch euch. Und wenn ihr mehr dazu wissen wollt, dann geht einfach auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Da erfahrt ihr alles Wichtige auch zur Regustierung und wie man uns unterstützen kann. Stellvertretend geht der Dank heute an SGE Le Smou, Tortinator Danny Chilien– ich habe keine Ahnung, ob ich das richtig ausspreche– und Kevin. Sonst erscheint am Montagabend die Spieltags-Sendung zum ersten Spieltag in der Bundesliga der Frauen. Max spricht damit Miri Schel und Adriana Wehrens. Und jetzt kommen die absoluten Skills aus meinem Deutschkurs nicht. Es wird auch eine Sendung, wenn ihr das hört, hier zu den Länderspielen der Männer erschienen sein. Von heute Abend, in dem Sonntagsabend auf, nach dem Spiel gegen Nordirland, wird aufgenommen, soweit ich weiß. Und sonst ist Marc in zwei Wochen wieder hier zu hören, sage ich jetzt einfach mal. Dann dürft ihr mit ihm wieder Vorlieb nehmen. Mich hört ihr sonst am nächsten Sonntag wieder für die Spieltagsbesprechung bei den Männern. Und bevor ich meine Gäste verabschiede, noch eine letzte Empfehlung für, und zwar für ein brandaktuelles Statement des Dachverbands für Fan-Hilfen. Da gab es heute ein bundesweites Treffen gegen die zunehmende Kriminalisierung von Fußballfans, auch im Zuge von März. Aussagen zuletzt. Und da wurden folgende Forderungen eben auch auf diesem Treffen beschlossen. Also einmal, dass man generell einfach sämtliche Pläne des sogenannten Sicherheitsgipfels aus dem vergangenen Herbst aufgibt. Unter anderem eben auch, dass die Vereine ein öffentliches und unmissverständliches Zeichen gegen die Hetzejagden gegenüber ihren Fans setzen. Verbot von Schuss- und Sprühwaffen sowie tasern der Polizei in den Stadien. Und eben auch eine Weiterbildung von Polizeieinheiten durch Aufnahme von Pflichtmodul, Fan-Kultur und Grundrechte um Gottes Willen in der Polizeiausbildung. Und eben auch ein langfristiger Kulturwandel und Abbau des Feindbildfans. Ich habe euch das ganze Statement mal verlinkt. Finde ich generell auch ein immer wieder wichtiges Thema. Es gibt sicherlich Sachen, die kann man immer wieder ambivalent diskutieren. Aber ich glaube dennoch, es ist wichtig, dass man eben die Fan-Hilfen, die Fan-Projekte weiterhin unterstützt. Die machen nämlich an jedem Standort eigentlich einen brutal wichtigen Job. Und den darf man auf gar keinen Fall unterschätzen. Das ist noch mein Schluss-Pilotier am Ende. Jetzt will ich aber meinen Gästen danken, die hier trotz kleiner Anlaufschwierigkeiten gut durchgehalten haben. Zum einen danke an Thomas Haufe. Danke, dass du mal wieder dabei warst.
Ja, danke für die Einladung und schönen Abend noch.
Und natürlich auch großen Dank an Kevin Bublitz vom Pardakast. Schön, dass auch du, ich glaube, dein jetzt insgesamt sechstes Mal, wenn ich richtig nachgeguckt habe, dabei gewesen bist.
Danke schön.
Und gestern vierhundertstes Mal Pardakast.
Stellt euch vor, ich hätte Konfetti mitgebracht und wäre vorbereitet gewesen.
Und ich habe heute fast gar nicht über einen SCP gesprochen. Das ist das erste Mal hier gewesen.
Ja, komm mal, das ist Respekt, das ist wie bei mir. Also ich habe das Wort Aminia heute sehr wenig in den Mund genommen. Ich möchte, also…
Obwohl die eigentlich auch zu den Gewinnern der Transferperiode gewinnt.
Ja, das können andere Leute besprechen.
Ich glaube, bevor ich mich jetzt selber ins Aus noch reite zum Ende dieser Folge, freue ich mich weiterhin über euer Feedback oder wir freuen uns darüber. Schreibt ins Forum, was ihr darüber denkt oder in den sozialen Medien. Und sonst wünsche ich euch ganz viel Spaß mit dieser Woche. Am Wochenende ist dann endlich wieder 2. Liga Fußball. Bis dahin macht's gut, bleibt gesund. Tschüss!
Das war der Rasenfunk.
Wir freuen uns über ihre Unterstützung.
Du lernst ein bisschen Geschichte und dann werden sie sehen, Herr Reporter, wie sich das damals im Parlament entwickelt hat.